things start making a 51% of the time
they make the right choice and 49% of
the wrong it's going to be a very
inefficient system to do all the error
correction to correct for that and so
there's this is why we often the Moore's
law the end of its being predicted
simply because we are getting time to
these tiny tiny scales first time I came
across integrated circuits was when I
was lucky enough to be working years ago
at a corn at the time at which Steve
Furber and Roger Wilson we're designing
the ARM processor and at that point we
were all very excited about three micron
technology that was the feature size of
the transistors three microns which
today is huge and today we're doing at
you know 28 and 22 nanometers Waterfalls
interesting we'll be hearing about it
for years first coined back in the
seventies by Gordon Moore of Intel at
the time it was an empirical observation
there was an observation of the number
of components that can be built on an
integrated circuit and their cost it's
often simply quoted as you know every
generation we are doubling in perplexity
but slightly more nuanced than that we
look at the cost I'm going to use a log
scale here so we're gonna go 110 100,000
and the four and along here we'll look
at number of components Moore's
observation was over a series of time we
started off the cost was quite high and
we could integrate you know some small
number of components and as you added
more and more components the cost per
component went back up so the point is
there was a sweet spot that was a there
was a size of semiconductor of
integrated semiconductor that was most
cost-effective he first time the group
this was 1962 what he observed was that
at each generation it was a sweet spot
and that's what's often referred to as
Moore's law is the doubling every
generation and the generation is each
time we reduce what we refer to as the
feature size of the component so we
reduce the size of the
sister and the wire and of course if we
have the dimension of it then because
it's a flat surface
we quadruple x for the number of
components we get on the chip first time
I came across integrated circuits was
when I was lucky enough to be working
years ago at acorn at the time at which
Steve Furber and Roger Wilson were
designing the ARM processor and at that
point we were all very excited about
three micron technology that was the
feature size of the transistors three
microns which today is huge and today
we're doing at you know 28 and 22
nanometers much smaller feature size so
what what does that actually name
everybody thinking about you know how we
actually manufacture semiconductors just
to get an understanding of and when
we're referring to these you know what
does this mean and then some of the
issues that we'll get eventually as we
shrink these devices small and smaller
we'll get to the issues that are causing
us concerns about Moore's law and the
fact that it's you know it's slowing
down and we can't continue forever
the original transistors were actually
made by just lobbing together of various
bits of semiconductor material and in
fact there's a brilliant picture you'll
be able to find the first transistor by
Shakti when he was at Bell Labs just
showing you how this stuff was glued
together but essentially to build a
transistor we need some semiconductor
materials that that are doped with ions
that give them either a slightly you
know and a lack of electrons in their
crystal structure or an excess of
electrons and they're either referred to
as P or n materials which we refer to as
P doping or n doping of the
semiconductor material so when we build
silicon chips taking a cross-section of
some silicon material then we dope an
area of it
with what we refer to as this P material
and then maybe another area with these n
material in it
and as we apply electric charge to this
we switch on and off the current flow
through this area of the semiconductor
and that gives us the basic switching
function we need and from
we can build up all the more complex
logic gates in order to build this the
way we do it is very similar to
photography a process called lithography
where we started with our semiconductor
material and we put a mask over the top
of it then we diffuse in from a gas lots
of our little molecules here flying
around this p-type material it diffuses
into the silicon and that gives us our
doped region and then the next step it's
similar thing we start off with our
existing region and then we put on a
different resistance layer and then we
do it with our n-type material and we
build up this small zone we obviously do
it for less time so it doesn't go all
the way through and this process of
laying on resistant material and then
itching it off the material is
photosensitive we've put up essentially
a negative on top of that the chip show
you shiny
ultraviolet light through it and the
photoresist reacts under that and then
we can etch it away with some chemical
leaving some of the resist and then we
can dope and that's very similar to how
we've built printed circuit boards for
years it's just a little much smaller
scale so as we want to build smaller and
smaller transistors we've had to
understand how to build essentially the
masks for the chips and these piece of
masks are multiple layers including not
just the P and the N layers but also
metal layers as well for the wiring on
the chip it's it's each generation has
required better understanding more
complex optical systems and and all
sorts of things like that so that's what
we're going on for years and that's the
this the same mechanism these are the
basis of all integrated circuits whether
their processors whether they're whether
memory devices there are subtle
distinctions in the details of the
layerings and the type of dope rings we
use that make them more efficient for
one use or another
silicon is not the only material used
for semiconductors for example for
photonic devices for lasers we often use
things like gallium arsenide which is
for called 3 5 semiconductors so long
but it's the basis of all our silicon
chips and
in essence know as these feature sizes
get smaller and smaller we start getting
to the point where if we look at these
areas of the transistor at some point as
we shrink this the question is how many
atoms are there in here or ions of the
dopant material and as it gets smaller
and smaller the number gets less and
less and that therein lies one problem
which is as we get to very small numbers
of atoms the behavior we rely upon the
quantum mechanics behavior of the
transistor the probability that it
switches in the right way starts to
start you know the chances that does the
right thing and start to reduce all
right there's always been a problem with
any of these systems there's usually two
places in which it is stable and you're
trying to switch from one place to the
other and it's just the probability that
these will do the wrong thing and as we
get down to tiny tiny transistors
there's a serious problem that there
aren't many atoms that are actually at
the heart of making that decision and if
they don't all jump decide to jump the
same way then it may not do what we
expect so the prediction of Moore's law
that it will run out is a statement of
the transistors you know starting to do
the unlikely thing too often and the
point at which you know we've used error
correction and other techniques to try
to correct the problems that we're
getting you know that will take us so
far but at some point you know if the
things start making a 51% of the time
they make the right choice and 49% of
the wrong it's going to be a very
inefficient system to do all the error
correction to correct for that and so
there's this is why we offer Moore's Law
the end of its being predicted simply
because we are getting down to these
tiny tiny scales there's plenty of other
things we still have available to us I
mean many modern ships have vast arrays
of the chip that are just laid down to
memory arrays and we can ask questions
about you know are they the best
architectures given we have so many
billions of transistors are we doing the
best thing with them and then finally
something that actually bits back a long
way as well I often find myself going
back to what seems like prehistory of
computing from any but
back in the days when I did my PhD one
of my colleagues did work on 3d chip
design where we stack up the chips on
top of each other and hence continue to
get you know doublings in density within
a certain area doesn't quite get us the
same cost savings but it does give us
the ability to have very dense computing
systems by stacking and we've already
seen that a number of commercial
products that come available
things that can affect this radiation
there's one problem only that will fall
over that won't move here we go ready
[Applause]
and that's for one of the reasons that
for example when we build chips to go
into satellites or into deep space
missions we take extreme measures to
protect the material